do you want a second referendum well to
be honest after the bitter divisive
experience last time I'm somebody who's
not a talking on a second referendum am
I surprised that so many people do you
want the second referendum no look I'm
not somebody it could be construed as
some sort of you're very fanatic I huge
reservations about the EU I campaigned
to stay on the basis of remain and
reform and when we lost the referendum
result I accepted that but let's just
look back at what's happened we were
promised by Liam Fox that negotiating a
deal with the EU would be the easiest
thing in the world the likes of David
Davis echoed that whenever any of us not
even criticized even scrutinized the
process we were called enemies of the
people
saboteurs traitors and mutineers and
worse and then what happens we have the
government now talking about a No Deal
scenario where we will have an I'm
quoting Dominic Raab the brexit
secretary adequate food where we will
have stockpiling of food and medicine
and where the army will be on standby to
distribute food and medicine they didn't
put that on the side of a big red bus
did they and the reality is we have a
Conservative government now in hoc
obviously to the hardcore ideologically
driven reck cities who risk driving this
country over the cliff with a No Deal
brexit which will cause calamitous
potentially economic consequences for
this country so no I'm not surprised
people are disillusioned and those con
men who made all these promises history
will be very damning I think for what
they've done
Jonathan your view Jonathan it sounds as
we heard from Owen calamitous would you
agree I think some of the predictions of
doom and gloom and calamity coming from
continuity remain campaigners are
frankly quite irresponsible they have
spent the last 18 months or so since the
referendum rather than constructively
trying to engage with delivering the
result of brexit of the referendum which
the public voted for they've been
seeking to undermine the result to try
and reverse the result that challenge
the result basically do anything but
accept the result and make breaks at
work which it absolutely should be able
to do and I think those who are
promoting those those irresponsible
Geir stories I mean over the weekend we
were told that brexit might cause the
spread of super gonorrhea for goodness
sake know there are some real
irresponsibility
real real irresponsible scare stories
being put about there which I think
there should not be the case on the same
token and I think the government
absolutely needs to reassure the public
you talk there about the no deal
planning that the government is doing we
know they've been doing that over a
period of time frankly they should be
more open and answering a lot of the
nonsense that's coming out and
explaining what is being done in a sober
and sensible fashion so that people know
that the government is on top of all of
this never take responsibility look you
the people he's arguing gates there have
nothing to do with me if you want
somebody was an arch to be an arts
critic of the remain campaign the
official remain campaign and continuity
remain I'm your guy they were a dire
campaign this awful corporate
establishment campaign and continuity
official remain campaigners who have
refused to learn the mistakes of that
last campaign in a country which is
disillusioned with a broken status quo
in a society which is rigged against
their interests so I have no sympathy
with official remained campaigners but
this is what we're talking about now
they made promises to us the official
leave campaign did they not booming
Britain prosperity we've ended up with
the worst growth of any advanced country
a stagnation of wages we've now gone
through the worst squeeze in wages of
any industrialized country other than
Greece that squeeze remained so you've
come back after the referendum they
promised us the easiest possible deal
and they're now talking about
stockpiling food and medicine and the
army patrolling the streets distribute
those desperately needed goods which we
all rely on to survive that's what this
is about
this is about because it's not scare
mongering this is literally the official
preparations for No Deal brexit and we
have people like this who come on
television and instead of taking
responsibility they always blame other
people we lost I accept we lost the
referendum your guys are now in
venting it we're heading to the walls
and Odile brexit you wanted now you have
to take responsibility for what you
wanted this is on you now not the
remainders not people like me who've
lost the referendum this is on you
Jonathan it's on you and your kind well
see I don't want to know deal brexit I
think there's every reason that we
should have a reasonable deal between
the UK and the European Union it would
be in both our interests to do so but at
the same time I don't think we should
accept a punishment deal from the
European Union which is what some are
suggesting could happen and no the
government needs to repair every
scenario if if the government weren't
preparing for every scenario I dare say
Owen will be the first person out there
saying it was irresponsible of the
government not to be doing that and
making all that kind of preparation it's
important they do do that but you've got
a lot of people who are saying we need a
second referendum now all the people who
are saying we want another referendum
now are people who didn't like the
result of the first one the fact is we
had a referendum more people voted for
brexit than voted for anyone or anything
in British electoral history and it's
incumbent on the government to deliver
on that result because failure to do so
or some kind of attempt to reverse that
result will create the most cataclysmic
constitutional crisis for you that's the
way but that's the way we voted that's
what the government has to make work who
is who is the argument gates here I've
said at the very beginning of what I
said that I don't support a second
referendum this country was plunged into
an extremely divisive referendum last
time we have bitter divisions of assault
we've not had in peacetime in this
country as a consequence so I don't know
who's arguing against we have to find a
way yes of making brexit work for
example with a customs union to prevent
a hard border in Ireland and also to
secure prosperity that's not what
Jonathan wants he wants a brexit which
is impossible which is why because the
Conservatives and it's the reason they
are doing what he wants which is to
argue for deal which is not on the table
that's why we're heading for no get
Brett and I wouldn't just ask him a very
straight question we'll be not misled by
those politicians who said that brexit
would be one of the easiest things in
the world that we'd easily negotiate a
trade bill with the European Union must
be honest now Jonathan what the years
the public misled yes don't try and take
blame others for what was promised
because people knew we were warned
people on the other side said that the
EU would not accept such a deal that it
would not be a walkover
so don't try and use the EU as a
scapegoat were we not misled by
politicians on the leave side who made
it out like this would be a walk in the
park I can't answer the question
not at all because back in March the EU
themselves Michel Barnier
talked about putting a free trade
agreement in the style of the Canada
deal on the table for Britain to take
and that's exactly the style of deal
that is one that we should be seeking
again we've had now the checkers
agreement which to be honest we don't
know where that lies he's gone Michel
Barnier effectively killed it off last
ride there we go there we go non-starter
is it not was it not the case that those
who said it would be a walk in the park
were challenged and those on the other
side said it wouldn't be a walk in the
park
has it been a walk in the park has this
been the easiest thing to do that's what
we were promised by the likes of Liam
Fox has that happened well the
government has not taken up the European
Union on the suggestion of a Canada SAR
free-trade agreement which is now is
exactly what they should be aiming at
right now just want to answer the
question which particular one the
question that's just been posed by owen
would you like interstate again i will
ask it again we were promised by
politicians on the leaf sidelines Liam
Fox that this would be one of the
easiest things in the world has that
happened yes or no okay it hasn't
because the the government has not taken
up the EU on its suggestion of a Canada
style deal which is exactly what they
should be doing now again I mean they
just never take responsibility the fact
is the deal that you wish at the moment
the the likes of Jacob Riis mode for
hard right at the Conservative Party
what they've been pushing for is just
not palatable it's not going to happen
which is why clearly what we should be
arguing for is a customs union
maybe European Union not least the
safeguard peace in Northern Ireland but
seconds to you go we can't be the
customs union with the European Union
cuz we wouldn't have come
roll of trade policy and part of the
referendum was about voting to take back
control of our trade policy about single
does our laws our money and government
needs to ensure that it delivers on that
result because if it doesn't then faith
in the process will be massively dent
well to me again very soon thank you
both very much indeed for joining us we
really appreciate it